so it's the pleasure to have my candy
visiting us today from Zoom
um Mark is a senior scientist at NTT
research and assistant professor at
Princeton University he's done a lot of
important work on post Quantum crypto
and more recently in Quantum algorithms
and complexity
um he's had a recent breakthrough result
on provable Quantum Advantage but today
I think he's going to tell us more about
the quantum algorithm side so mark
all right thank you for the introduction
um yeah so I'll be talking about the
basically the core algorithmic technique
that we use in our recent Quantum
Advantage work
um so let's let's start with the
classical world and imagine that I have
two distributions uh you know maybe this
comb here and a gaussian here and what I
want to do is somehow multiply them and
what I mean by that is take the two
distributions as input and produce an
output distribution where the point wise
probabilities are the product of the
pointwise probabilities of the input
distribution now uh the the point was
product won't be properly normalized but
what we would want is that the
distribution has uh probabilities
proportional to the product
and what I really mean when I say this
is I we I want to imagine that we have
an efficient algorithm for sampling D1
and an efficient algorithm for sampling
D2 and I want to somehow combine these
into an efficient algorithm for sampling
um this this product distribution that
I've defined
uh now in general there's no reason to
think that this is possible and in fact
it it will be you know sort of nonsense
in general
um
so you know to think about like how do
we make use of both Samplers each
sampler we just run and we get a a
sample from some distribution how do we
possibly use that to generate a single
sample from a different distribution
um it's not clear and to make matters
worse the
um the product distribution is actually
just uh not defined for some in some
cases for example if D1 and D2 have
disjoint supports the product
distribution doesn't make sense the the
point-wise products are zero everywhere
there's no distribution
um so so clearly something is going to
go wrong in full generality
um and even if we sort of ignore that
issue with the existence of the product
distribution and just say okay maybe we
only care about distributions that have
overlapping support uh well we still
wouldn't expect this to be done to
doable efficiently because in full
generality it would imply an efficient
algorithm for NP um this isn't hard to
see
okay uh so this seems like we're we're
not going to be able to do this
okay
so so in this work what we what we
looked at is something that looks very
similar
um except that instead of multiplying
distributions we're going to try to
multiply Quantum States
uh so I have you know this the same
pictures but now instead of thinking of
these as distributions I'm going to
think of these as
um the the amplitudes of some Quantum
state
right uh but it's the same problem so I
have I have some Quantum state that has
amplitudes in this picture you know it's
a positive amplitudes on the comb is
there everywhere else
um and this one it's you know some
gaussian weighted uh superposition and I
want to compute the product state where
the the amplitudes on every Point are
the pointwise products of the amplitudes
of the original state and again there's
an issue of normalization here
um but that that's that's going to be
the goal
and note that uh having a Quantum State
uh you can always measure the state and
get a sample from some distribution uh
where the outputs are proportional to
the squared amplitude so
basically what we're hoping for here is
some sort of uh I have stronger inputs
rather than getting a sampler I'm
actually given a Quantum state which
implies a sampler and I want to somehow
multiply these together to get an A
Quantum State for the product state
which again which then implies a sampler
for the product distribution so stronger
input stronger outputs
uh but but nevertheless there's still
maybe no reason to think this is
possible uh you know it looks it looks
superficially at least very similar to
the classical case of distributions you
have these two Quantum States how do you
make use of uh generators for these two
Quantum states to make some single state
you know the the algorithm you have two
algorithms that produce these each of
these Quantum States how do you how do
you combine them in a meaningful way
um and just like the classical case it's
going to be undefined or impossible if
the support searches joint and also in
full generality this would imply an
efficient algorithm for NP
so again we don't we don't expect to be
able to do this in full generality
um and it's maybe a priority unclear how
we could do this in a special in in even
special cases
uh but the the point of of this talk is
to show that actually there are some
cases where we can do this in a
meaningful way and
um this leads to interesting results
so what we're going to do is let's just
look at the Fourier domains we're going
to look at the Fourier domain for our
two input States and also the Fourier
domain for the output State this is a
very natural thing to do Quantum 4A
transforms are one of the core building
blocks of many or most of the quantum
algorithms we know and so we might as
well apply the quantifory transform to
everything and see what happens
so when I take the 4A transform of my
input States I get new states with
different amplitudes here denoted by
these Alpha hat and beta hats
and what is the output state of of the
of the product state so what does the
product State look like in the Fourier
domain
uh well it turns out that we actually
know exactly what this looks like in
terms of the Fourier domain
um versions of the input States and this
is the convolution theorem
and it says that the Fourier transform
of the product
is the convolution of the Fourier
transforms of the inputs and here in the
KET notation the convolution has this
nice form it's the sum over all X and Y
where X ranges over the domain of the
one state y ranges over the domain of
the other states uh we get an X Plus y
term and the coefficient or the
amplitude on X Plus Y is Alpha hat beta
y alpha x had beta y times
all right so if we can what this shows
is that if we can convolve the two
states
then we can actually multiply them right
you just uh
well here I have the outline here so if
if you want to multiply two two states
the first thing you do is you just
construct each one of them we're we're
assuming the ability to do this
uh we switched to the Fourier domain by
performing The quantum 40 transform
and if we just put these two states next
to each other and look at their uh look
at the Joint system what we get is
something that looks almost like what
we're aiming for it's uh you know sum
over X Y Alpha hat X Theta hat y uh but
instead of X Plus y here we have X comma
y so that's that's you know that's the
only thing that's keeping us from uh
achieving our goal
um so now what we do is we just add them
in superposition this is a basic
operation we can easily do uh as long as
we make sure it's unitary and that's
important so we just simply have the
classical map that Maps X comma y to X
comma y comma X Plus y
then we apply this in superposition
so we can we can apply this map
here and now we have this state that has
an x a y and an X Plus y so we got the X
Plus y that we wanted all along
but we're not quite done
right we we need to somehow get rid of
the X comma y if we could get rid of the
X comma y we're left with X Plus y
and we can forward a transform back and
actually get the product state that we
desired
um so what we need is some decoding
procedure that takes X Plus Y and
actually computes X and Y or it's really
enough to just compute say x right
because if you have X Plus Y and X you
can recover y just by subtraction
right so this is this is going to be the
uh our blueprint so construct the state
separately
uh move to 4A domain add in
superposition and then there's this last
decoding step to uncompute uh these
leftover X and Y terms
and you know uh just to reiterate we're
given that we can construct these
separately so we're we're given step one
step two step two is is easy
and uh step three is where all the
difficulties lie
um and and in fact because we know that
we don't expect to be able to
um construct the product States in
general we don't expect this decoding
process to be possible in general
um and in fact you know it's easy to
come up with examples where where the
decoding where you know you know think
about it X Plus y uh came from you know
whatever the domain of the states are
there's there's but somehow we have to
decode X comma y there's a lot more
information in X comma y the next plus y
twice as twice as many uh qubits an X
comma Y is X Plus y
um so we're only going to be able to
decode in very special situations where
um you know X and Y sort of are are very
constrained so that X Plus y uniquely
determines both X and Y
EP all right and just to reiterate to
see we'll see what it might look like
when when things when you when you can
multiply when you cannot we can consider
uh the case that I had pictured before
where I had my
um my comb and I had a you know some
narrow gaussian here
and here what happens when I convolve is
basically I just get a bunch of copies
of the gaussian shifted according to the
spikes in the comb
and in and in this picture the spikes
are pretty far apart and so my my
gaussians that I get in my gaussian comb
are are pretty far apart and they'll
have they'll have negligible overlap
basically zero overlap
and so if you were to give me a point on
here on on anywhere in the product state
if you're to give me a point I could
actually uniquely determine the X and Y
I came from right the basically which
hump it came from tells me which spike
in the comb and where in the hump
relative to the center of the hump told
tells me where I came from in the in the
gaussian so in in this case actually the
decoding is possible at least up to some
some negligible error because there will
be some you know tiny bleed up between
the Tails of the gaussian
um but what happens if the you know
instead of uh you know a nice comb on
the left here I actually had uh maybe uh
you know something a bit smoother like
this
well now when I can solve with the
gaussian uh I'm still gonna get
something that has all all these Peaks
uh but now the Tails of the gaussen
really are bleeding together quite
significantly and if you were to give me
a point on on one of these humps
you know you don't know if that point
that's you know that's this is X Plus y
on on one hump over here on on the right
you don't know if that's uh you don't
know how to uniquely decode that as X
Plus y it could have been that it came
from you know one hump over here or it
could have been the adjacent hump uh we
just there's no way to know until
there's no way to uniquely decode
okay
um
okay so with that in mind
um I I want to say where where's where
the algorithm was this uh algorithm is
used uh first at least as far as I know
um and this was uh due to a famous
result of of regev
um and so in his case he was looking at
a very special case of this multiplying
Quantum States
um where what are the two input States
so so the one state is the indicator
function for some linear code C
or think of it as just a you know a
sequence of linear equations over a
finite field
um and the other state is a what's
called a discrete gaussian so a
multivariate discrete gaussian so it's
like a gaussian except it only has uh
you know amplitude on on integers
and if you take the product State what
you get
uh because this gaussian here only has
short integer vectors in its support
the product state are short integer
vectors satisfying a system of linear
equations you know belonging to the
linear code
so the product state is a superposition
over short vectors in C
and if you measure that state you get
you know a random short Vector in in the
code and
um solving this problem is is what's
known as a short integer solution
problem or CIS
right so this is this is a famous hard
problem in computer science and also
specifically in cryptography given us
some of random linear equations find
find a short vector
um and so that that that was the
reggae's goal in considering uh this
and uh when you switch to the Fourier
domain what you get well before you
transform of the of these Alpha X's is
actually just another indicator function
but this time for the Dual code
um or you know thinking of it as linear
algebra it's the the Dual space of the
um
linear equations and the Fourier
transform of a gaussian is another
gaussian uh with a with a different
width
and now when you convolve these
what you get is something that looks
like a multi-dimensional version of the
of the picture that I had pictured for
our example uh right so the indicator
functions for for a linear Subspace is
kind of like the is a multi-dimensional
version of the comb and then you have
the you know this this gaussian here
and what this ends up being is you get
you get a state where the where you have
a bunch of gaussian poles centered at
the the
um the Dual code points and this is
known as bounded distance decoding uh
perhaps more famously known as learning
with errors
um and basically
um you know reggae was trying to solve
this and realize that he could solve it
if he could
um you know solve this learning with
theirs problem
uh but you know it turns out that uh you
know maybe now we believe that actually
both are hard
um and so you can turn this on his head
and say well uh because we don't you
know if you were to believe that CIS is
hard that there there is no Quantum
algorithm for CIS well that actually
implies a Quantum algorithm for the
hardness of learning Affairs so so we're
we're regive you know failed to actually
complete the algorithm because he it was
unable to come up with an algorithm for
this learning Affairs problem uh this
this approach actually you could turn it
on its head and use it as a hardness
justification to convince yourself that
learning with errors is actually is
actually hard uh you know assuming the
hardness of the sort into a solution
problem which is you know a famous
problem with connections to hard
problems on lattices and and widely
believed to be
hard
okay so so this was reggae's first
example sort of a a failure uh to to
instantiate this multiplying Quantum
States algorithm but actually turn into
a very useful proof of hardness for
learning with errors
and uh you know now I'll finally get to
to our setting where we actually give a
positive application of quantum State
multiplication
um and our our problem is going to look
a little bit similar we're also going to
have a a linear code be our our alpha x
our first input state
um but then what we're going to do is
we're going to restrict it in a
different way instead of restricting it
to
um you know short integer Solutions uh
to the code we're going to restrict it a
little differently and what we're going
to do is we're going to go coordinate by
coordinate
and uh just you know arbitrarily throw
away a half of the coordinates and say
you know you're only a valid solution if
your coordinate is you know is in the
subset of size you know roughly half of
the of all the x coordinates and we'll
do this by querying some hash function H
so this hash function will put a single
bit and will tell us whether the x
coordinate is in the is allowed or not
um and then we you know still do this
for exponents and we'll we'll randomly
throw away half of the valid Y
coordinates half of the valid Z
coordinates and so forth and and
eventually get
um you know we've thrown away roughly
half of every single coordinate and now
your goal is to come up with a set of
valid coordinates that also happens to
satisfy the linear constraints of the
code
all right so so that's our problem and
what we are going to do now is try to
multiply Quantum States in order to
solve it and we'll see that in our case
we actually can can do this
um so so our two input states are as
follows our first input state is again
the indicator function for a linear code
just like in I guess
um our beta X are going to be what's
different there's no gaussians here
instead our our beta X are going to be
the indicator function for for valid
coordinates or really tuples of valid
coordinates
um
right and then the the product will be
you know solutions to the linear
equations for the code that happen to
all have valid coordinates which will be
will show exactly be solutions to our
our problem that we defined
foreign Okay so
uh I guess the first thing to remark is
that you know both the alpha x State and
the beta X State we we can efficiently
construct these are easy the alpha axis
is just linear algebra and the the beta
X these indicator functions you can
easily do also
um just some simple uh rejection
sampling
um and so what really remains in order
to to get an algorithm for this problem
is to solve the decoding problem so so
what is
the decoding problem
uh well let's think about remember the
convolution of the Fourier transforms of
the two input States
so the one input States uh just like in
reggae was the Dual code of whatever
code we're using
um so it's just a
um
yeah sort of a set of points
um and then for the valid coordinate
part this is going to depend on on what
hash function you use uh we we will
assume a random hash function so so
basically the for each coordinate we'll
assume that the hash function for that
coordinate just hashes every
uh input down to a random bit
uh and we'll we'll you know
heuristically treat it as a as a uniform
and a bit for every single foot
right so our our if we zoom into just a
single coordinate our our state just
looks like it looks like a mess it's
just this sort of randomly oscillating
between zero and one up to normalization
um but this random mess actually has a
really nice form in the Fourier domain
uh because you know the the integral
under this random mess is roughly a half
because of you know half the time we're
at one half the time at zero what this
means is in the Fourier domain uh our
Fourier coefficient at 0 has amplitude
roughly a half
and everywhere else all the other
Fourier coefficients uh
go away they they write the randomness
here sort of ends up causing the other
Fourier coefficients to be negligible
um so so actually we have a you know
there's a complex phase in in all these
Fourier coefficients that encodes all
the randomness in our our state uh but
if you just look at the amplitudes the
the Fourier domain is is very nice form
right so so our our product States then
in the Fourier domain remember it's a
superposition over X Plus y
X is a random dual code word
uh and Y
uh is is this thing that in every
coordinate has amplitude a half on zero
and is otherwise you know sort of
uniformly spread out across the domain
uh so so Y is going to be this sort of
noise term that uh is zero and half of
the coordinates roughly half the
coordinates and and has random arrows in
the other half the coordinates so I have
a dual code word plus random errors and
half the coordinates
and it turns out that this is actually
uh decoding from X Plus y recovering X
and Y from this is actually a well-known
problem this is just uh sort of the
usual setting of error correcting codes
right and uh the except we're just
correcting for the Dual codeword instead
of the original code word
right so that you know this is exactly
what we're doing in error correction
where you you take your your code and
you sort of scramble some fraction of
the coordinates and make them something
else
now in the regime that we care about
where you have errors in half the
coordinates you can't use unique uh uh
decoding in the in the traditional sense
uh but but you can use list decoding
um and use the fact that the errors are
random to guarantee that you succeed in
decoding
uh and so what we show is that if you're
if you actually do model your hash
function as a as a random function
uh then you can actually you can
actually decode efficiently and from X
Plus y recover X and Y separately with
high probability assuming the the Dual
code is list decodable for half
perceptual inflection of errors
uh and we and we know how to construct
these
um these list decodable codes this is
well known
um and and then that's uh that's more or
less it that's our that's our algorithm
uh there's there's
um why do we care about this contrived
problem I'll just briefly say that we we
show that this problem is actually
um or we give evidence anyway that this
problem is actually hard for classical
computers this requires more properties
on the code
um and sort of
um you know a conjecture that are you
know random hash function heuristic is
is valid uh but but it's you know some
some pretty convincing evidence I think
um and this uh what's interesting is
it's the first Super polynomial
Advantage for NP that doesn't rely on on
period finding
um and it's also the first example super
polynomial advantage that doesn't uh
rely on tools from public key
cryptography just just hash functions
um no no public key crypto systems
um and I guess I'll just you know so
this is the the end of the talk and I'll
just leave it with sort of this
interesting open question of there we
now have this we have this technique of
multiplying Quantum States that's been
used you know both for you know negative
results showing hardness of problems and
also for positive results
um you know that we use for Quantum
advantage and it seems really like
there's probably a lot more here
um than this than just these two
isolated examples what else can this
technique be used for is there you know
any anything exciting that can be done
um and that's it for my talk thanks